hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to darkwood
i know that i was again upset at the end
of the last episode
but it's weird how i'm still compelled
to keep playing
i think that's reflective of the idea
that the game's choices
are actually impactful whether or not
like i had the intention of trying to
help him
i also didn't think about the
consequences of putting a mushroom that
i was using to modify
my character in the hands of a kid who
was already mutated so
like it's it sucks it really sucks
because i wouldn't have wanted this
and knowing that there was an
alternative really hurts
but at the same time it it just means
like a lot of what i did through this
game
was always just like what my first gut
reaction was
and i didn't necessarily think it
through i didn't think how it could
affect
the world around me and i bet a lot of
my choices in this game are reflective
of that
i had to kill a whole village just to
protect a kid because i trusted
the wolf and that came back to haunt me
i killed the pig
why because the wolf wanted me to for
fun because he didn't like to hear it
squealing it
it makes me question my judgment a lot
anyway so it said that it was gonna take
a full night cycle to
burn it down let me just prep my base
here i wasted a lot of time just
wallowing in misery
but you know it's fine it's whatever i
will live with my decisions
and that will be the end of it okay so
that's there had a bunch of wood here i
never really did barricade anything
i mean i guess i could while i'm here
never built these fences
i don't know what they what good would
they do anyway because i
like they'll climb over it and then
it'll still be the same deal unless they
can't climb fences but they can climb
windows they can definitely climb
fences i'll do it anyway i've got the
wood do i need all of these different
things
probably not but hey it feels good to
have them
ah let's put my sweater on because it
feels nice
i really don't need this much gun
i am aware that i don't i'll save the
pistol because if
the the biggest threat so far has been
the small
or i'll have the pistol on me has been
the small birds
so i guess i could have the assault
rifle pistol uh let's make
some traps i guess just in case anything
gets over the fence or should i put on
the other side
i guess i could have put it on the other
side from this side uh
let's put two why not
um yeah let's put another no one's
coming from down here that's for sure
hey bud don't worry pal everything's
gonna be fine
everything's gonna be a-okay
everything's gonna be great the
generator
okay that's good hey buddy i'm sorry
i'm really sorry about that i didn't
mean for that to happen if i ever play
this again which i might actually play
it on my own
i'll make sure that that's fixed
okay okay
light help me light
there's a light going on in there oh
why
ah why did you oh why did i do it you
know
okay cool good good good good good good
oh no man things are weird oh it burned
oh my god it's covered in a thick layer
well then
oh god i'm hurt ow okay don't do that
i could have drank from the well oh my
god my oh wait no hang on my whole plate
hey
wait wait a minute wait hang on
that's a problem oh oh hey how you doing
hello oh no
oh no well that's so good
i didn't plan for them to be in my base
yes normal oh yeah
all right reload reload reload reload
okay
oh hey okay all right pistol is a good
choice
hello all right i might need more ammo
actually i don't know why i'm using the
pistol i could probably just melee these
guys if they're that weak
hi schwampus oh god oh god oh god oh god
whompus ah gotta actually get close
yumpus ow yumpus
okay there's more of you yumpus all
right
yampus all right jumpus oh my god
there's a lot of you oh wait wait wait
wait whoa what the hell what the hell is
happening
what the hell is going on hey way way
way way oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
a pistol pistol oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god scream
yipes that's right run you
[ __ ] give me that ah i'm gonna drink
from the
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god i'll get go oh my
god shoot
damn it shoot holy [ __ ]
what the frick what the frick oh my god
assault rifle
assault rifle assault rifle any minute
now
shoot shoot god damn it shoot shoot
get out oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god
okay they don't do a lot of damage but
holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh my god oh god no
not that thing knocked out of my own
thing
[Music]
what oh no
that literally couldn't have gone worse
but where's the musician i would have
done things a lot differently if i had
known that they were going to be coming
in my base i would have done things a
lot differently
really hello okay
they're not here okay let's see what
happened to the tree
um there's nothing really here for me
all right i didn't bring potatoes or
anything but the potatoes betrayed me i
never should have trusted the potatoes
you know i bet the potatoes were a ruse
i never could have fed him that because
the potatoes were only gotten if you did
something terrible and you couldn't feed
him the
sins of his own potatoes maybe the
potatoes were what were infecting
everybody
that's a wind i don't remember being
here
interesting oh no
journal entry ashes what
it worked only ash's remain of the tree
i feel as
i'm approaching the end of my journey is
it possible i set the roots in the
cellar on fire the fire consumed the
talking tree in its entirety even now i
can still hear it screaming
seems like the [ __ ] was right the
tree is enormous and it will probably
continue burning throughout the night
i'll return here tomorrow he never ate
his fish
i could have had fish ah i could have
fed the kid fish i didn't even think
about that i mean i
i know i saw bread i don't know where
the old man
is hello
oh oh
oh no oh
oh [ __ ]
oh where am i oh
only ash's remained achievement oh
i need my light hello
hello hello
hello
it's just houses consumed by the trees
there's a lot of footsteps here these
are footsteps right
oh a colorless goose sips from the
cracks in the asphalt
oh
[Music]
oh hello
oh who's that torches do i need to burn
something i bet i do i'm gonna take both
of them just in case
the crosstalk sign reads dark wood yeah
well they were right about that
it is dark and there are wood hello
hi whoa huh
[Music]
hello it's a crippled old man from the
village
oh my god he's freaking going for it i
would
can i help you the road home dude can i
help you
did i pick you up i've literally only
actually been trying to help people this
whole time it just
all my actions seem to turn out badly
ignore the fact that i kill the whole
village
that probably doesn't look good on me
what the hell weirdly frozen people
just like oh my god this is so weird
why does the tree do this with the
people did it trap people as they were
trying to go along or
are these simply echoes that the the the
the tree recreated
because it was like an amalgamation of
people like what is
oh frick oh my god what the hell
oh what the hell oh god everything's
like blurring
oh weird this this must just be echoes
oh my god
what is this like everyone that i killed
that's so weird that's so weird
little truck 25 kilometers to the
nearest town
road ends over there yeah i guess
not really a surprise
weird okay
well this seems to be growing dense oh
oh [ __ ] oh well okay i guess they closed
in behind me
that's fine okay
weird
whoa what the hell
you know i just realized it i don't know
why it took me this long to realize it
but if you look at the shot the way the
shadows
are they look like trees rising like the
trunks actually rising up the shadows
are literally the projection of the
light but
at the same time it looks like the tree
trunk just rising up i don't know why
it's taking me that long to see that
perspective
because those are trees they're just cut
away to look like they're actually
full trees oh what the hell
what the hell
oh weird
hi and they're gone
who's gonna eat the bread now oh i
scared the birds away okay i'm sorry
i thought you were talking about
something else like someone you lost a
long time ago and i don't know
i didn't think of something so normal as
the birds
my first floor good day
i said i said word good day good day
good day good good day
what the hell
this is my stair oh boss hello
hi got any spare change oh you know no
not really
you're waking my kid sorry
get the hell away sorry hello
what the hell wait why did the music get
all creepy over there
oh what the hell okay dude oh my god
okay this is not normal okay this is all
stupid cow okay this is not normal
something's not right here elevator
doesn't work
hello
locked door someone finally evicted them
it's probably the work of that little
punk from the third floor
something's not right here
no this ain't right no this ain't right
please to see you mr haven't seen you in
a while you know how it is
they're still green even though i've
never seen anyone tending to them maybe
they feed on the discarded cigarette
butts
so that was my memory that was my memory
probably the work of the kids from the
third this door seems to be blocked from
the other side and this side
this is not right something is
very
something's very wrong
[Applause]
no some no
no no something's very wrong home sweet
home
no
it's my wardrobe
i should change first
what do you mean i should change first i
don't leave my apartment
[Music]
what the frick
what
i'll take a bath tomorrow i'm barely
standing up no
oh note is lying on the table i made you
some soup heated up
there's still some soup in the pot
no
[Music]
oh my god i could cry
oh oh
oh i could cry oh fine piece of fabric
fly a piece of bedroom key
fabric folding couch i can drag it
why would i want to be able to drag it
watch out boogie
sorry i just had to check oh no wise why
are things draggable here
oh no i know i know this is all fake
i know that this is all fake that this
is just a figment of my imagination i
am so aware of that i i know it but
oh my god good boy
there's a flashlight and a nine volt of
course there is
in the tv i can't even access my
inventory
this is all fake oh my god
i can't even run in here
smells fills the entire kitchen cook
grab the largest disc from the closest
under the sink and pour myself a bowl
it's not much but it's enough i don't
remember the last time i've eaten the
home dinner
oh that looks so good
i could cry
oh it's my bed
the white crumpled sheets looks like
i've just woken up
at last i feel my sore legs buckling
underneath me my body becoming heavy and
overly authentic
it was a grueling journey 26 days of
human torment leave
with my last strength i stop myself from
falling asleep something forces me to
move away from the bed did i forget to
do something
i know that this isn't real
i know that's not real i would love
to believe that was true and once again
it's one of those things where once you
step into it
it doesn't seem you can go back but i
know
that's not real there's a reason why the
save i think
is tosses you way back there's something
else to find
like that the the freaking fetus shaking
on the floor
told me everything i needed to know
there's no way
that i could have been through what i
went through
and just be able to go back to the way
life is
there's no way there's something else
going on here
oh wait is it this is it gonna loop uh
and they're gone yeah
is it looping does it loop it just loops
doesn't it i bet
that's what he was doing in the hallway
it was just looping
that's what it's doing i mean the lady's
not there but i bet if i go over here
i'm now two blocks up from where i was
my same neighbor hi
good day and if i go up here
oh she's gone weird but i bet this is
still
the right building
there that
something's not right something's all
right
something's not right
something's not right what is it
oh no
oh is there someone there hello
what oh my god that's a chomper what the
hell is with you
i knew it i knew it i knew it
i freaking knew it i knew it
i knew it i knew it
potatoes huh canned jars jar of jam
zemik
oh
no
no i will not go to sleep
wait wait a minute okay so now
i have a mushroom from the basement if i
go to my stove
and i cook this mushroom right because i
there was a stove and i cooked the soup
i bet that's it
i bet that's it it's a lie there's no
way
maybe maybe me eating the mushrooms from
the very beginning
maybe that's just something i assumed
you should do what if you
never do that what if you go through the
whole game cause cause to be perfectly
honest
i practically did go through the whole
game without using
the powers like i got all of them but i
only took advantage of the weaknesses
that i got
what if you never do how far down does
this haul we go
does it loop forever or is it just a
fake loop
oh oh
no oh no
oh no oh no
getting kind of dense in here maybe if i
just
done this from the get-go or maybe i had
to go to the basement
oh and it's clear okay weird now it's
not doing it anymore
now it's just perfectly normal okay i've
been looping for quite a while now
home sweet home sure yeah
wait no
oh [ __ ] god damn it did i
i [ __ ] up again did i [ __ ] up i [ __ ]
up didn't i
but at least i get to pet the dog again
hi
good boy wait a minute wait a minute i
did not [ __ ] up
i definitely did not [ __ ] up what the
[ __ ]
what is with that oh what the [ __ ]
okay okay oh something is up
oh something is up
roots examine these roots are growing
out from under the floor panels
yeah they are rug fold the rug
i knew it would that do
flooring remove there should be some
tools in the kitchen
i knew it was that doable before i
didn't even know
i covered under the sink large
screwdriver you got it
i'm so sorry pop
[Music]
pup oh my god
oh my god
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
look closer fighting off sleepiness with
difficulty i'd lean over the bed the
springs creak noisily under the weight
of my hand
as i cast my glance on the light brown
construction from plywood
i noticed familiar features they are
elongated and arched
i can still smell the fresh seats and
the pleasant warmth
of the quill look under the bed i feel a
gentle drought coming in from the dark
gap between the bed and the floor
reach under the bed my fingertips brush
a thin layer of dust
coldness moisture i'm touching something
rough
but my arm is too short to catch it i
think i need to move the bed
move the bed
[Music]
oh my god
oh my god i knew it
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] my hat
oh what the [ __ ] it's torn and covered
with dried mud
it was all a dream the man is fast
asleep he's smiling and hugging his
knees with skinny dirty arms a swarm of
flies is covering a black sword on his
back
oh my god that's what i did when i came
in
they're completely destroyed there's a
tunnel it's a meter wide tunnel covered
with a slimy membrane further inside i
can see pulsating gross blocking the way
ahead
i won't be able to pass through this way
it was all a dream
a steep slope blocks the way ahead there
are some tunnels at its base
people just [ __ ] tunneled through
came to here and fell asleep
and became part of the woods that's the
truth of it
i came in i thought i was in my
apartment i took up my coat and i was
about to go to sleep
but i fought it off because that wasn't
true these people couldn't know about it
the man doesn't react i'm unable to wake
him from his slumber
that's so awesome dirty clumped hair
covered the woman's face
she's murmuring in her sleep clutching a
ragdoll filled with straw
now the moon has faded the night
is here asleep soul over
my doll so close
your eyes the woman doesn't react i'm
unable to wake her from her slumber
i'm at the bottom of a huge valley i
feel the dry dress the earth pulsating
under my feet
the figure is talking in its sleep
moving its hand as if caressing someone
with affection
there's corpses of people that fell
asleep for too long they just faded away
the figure speaks to someone in its
sleep squeezing an old man's photo in
its hands
what the [ __ ] the face is covered with
mud and sticks
it clutches a shiny stone in his hand
the sleeping man looks like a skeleton
coated in skinny smiles wildly
i hear a fame whisper stasic my little
stazzy
sleep stazique that's someone from in
this
town the emanciated figure sleeps
soundly embracing the remains of a child
the figure sleeps on the muddy ground
resting its head on the chest of a
skeleton next to it i think that one
over there was a doctor
it clutches a muddy brass cross in both
hands repeating some incomprehensible
words in its sleep
they're all sleeping they're all just
part of the tree
it hums something quietly in its sleep
swaying to the rhythm of a simple metal
melody another sleeping figure another
sleeping figure
oh my god was
all of it a dream from the beginning and
that's why when i ate the mushrooms
and i went into the dream world things
were real there and i would have
gotten out but i wouldn't have really
gotten out i would have just gotten to
the point
where i had that chance to wake up was
any of it real
i mean obviously the tree is real
because it's here but the
reality of being in there is different
but they're all here everyone that was
in
that i interacted with was here that's
why death wasn't
real i would just wake up but i would
wake up back
in the tree you're not dead until you're
consumed that's why mutations
inside there they weren't actually real
the earth is covered with
thick bundles of dry roots that creak
under my feet and old broken trees
i guess in the end it doesn't really
matter what i did it doesn't really
matter what i did
so long as i got here i guess what the
hell
oh hey i don't know if it's important to
get these stones oh
well i picked them all up also i'm butt
naked
a pleasant warmth washes over me
oh uh hi you're butt naked too
um hi how are you
ah wow okay oh this is this is fantastic
this is fantastic this is hello
and once i before i talk to him that
seems important
see what this is all about oh wow
oh wow
okay okay
what the hell
okay these are definitely the savages
and i don't know what this
is but it's very reminiscent of all the
pulsating white goo
that's seeping out everywhere but okay
so let me process this for a second
clearly i woke up from a dream but the
difference between reality and dream
is not so different like
the woods are the way they are because
it's clear here that it is it's
physically doing something to the woods
maybe not everyone's a sleeper right
away or maybe everyone is
or maybe they just all lose themselves
over time
and come here to sleep forever and be
part of the woods and that's how they
become like
part of that talking tree or maybe the
talking tree is symbolic
i don't know there's someone here let me
just
quickly scan the area another throne
i again i don't know what the stones are
all about
huge roots block the way even if i
manage to climb them everything is
surrounded by steep
overgrowth of thick roots
so weird okay i think that was it looks
like everything
i get all the stones i don't know i
probably missed some
hello hi the man mumbles in his sleep
he's emaciated
and dirty but his face is radiant and
calm he clutches a rusty object covered
with old beads
some weapon listen to the murmurs the
man is talking in his sleep
there are only snippets of sentences
single words spoken gently
and slowly it's hard to find any meaning
in them push the figure
leave without opening his eyes the man
clumsily waves his hand at me
then covers his head with it and freezes
try to take the metal item from the man
leave the man waves his hand again this
time he grabs my arm
without opening his eyes he turns his
head towards me i recognize him
he's one of us who's us
take it leave can you [ __ ] hear me i
won't let you take her
the man clenches his teeth with the fury
of a maniac
saliva flows from his mouth it's hurting
her you'll tear her arms out
hit the man grab the eye
don't leave her oh my god
well i guess i said i was gonna hit the
okay
oh
oh oh i don't even have an inventory i
beg you
give her to me uh no what are you doing
nothing
leave us alone uh no
oh my god talk oh talk hey
let's talk i'm standing in front of
enormous being
place hand on the being should i do that
i couldn't do it before oh i feel an
overwhelming soothing feeling of
security and happiness
the vast valley at bottom which i stand
curves upward closing over my head
the rust of distant trees turns into a
single silent murmur
i feel i'm coming home to my flat to my
room with a window and a bed
withdraw my hand i feel a heat emanating
from the being
i sense my pulse slowing down a calmness
i want to rest
come back home to my bed i want to lie
down i want to fall asleep
withdraw my hand i don't want to do it
still my hand pushes the being away
the warmth that was emanating from it
disappears replaced by piercing
coldness so what did i get from him
i mean i got a flamethrower but what am
i gonna do with it oh i can leave now
i can go through the tunnel right of
course that was the whole point
going back makes no sense there's no way
out well okay then what do i what am i
doing
what am i doing here you'll kill us all
by what
what am i doing okay
oh doctor oh doc oh [ __ ] it's a doctor
he's fast asleep
okay am i supposed to be able to do this
uh what am i doing
the [ __ ] is ha
okay so i looked it up apparently i was
supposed to get that flamethrower and
then be able to use it
for some reason i wasn't and what i
think happened was
even though i can't access my inventory
apparently i still have an inventory
just like i still have a stamina bar for
running
so i think i what i i think what
happened is i picked up so many stones
that i could no longer carry anything
and therefore when i
picked up the thing i didn't actually
pick it up and it didn't drop it on the
ground and i couldn't access my
inventory to
drop anything else well anyway i'll be
right back
but that's a kick in the dick hi again
i'm back
uh yeah i think i think that's what
happened i also remembered that i picked
up so many things in the apartment and i
don't know if those carried over
i could i wouldn't be able to tell it's
my incessant need to check the
environment first
which for some reason sometimes has
gotten me in trouble and sometimes help
me
try to snatch it hit him and grab the
item
there it is yeah oh
oh wow oh he don't get up again oh my
god
oh my god oh my god
yeah i'ma [ __ ] burn this thing no
oh yeah [ __ ] burn it [ __ ] burn it
burn it all
[ __ ] burn it down oh
oh my god
dude you're they're saying you'll die
with us you're we're you'll kill us
all you're already dead we're we're
already dead
oh my god
holy [ __ ] i will stand here and make
sure that this all burns to the freaking
ground
oh wait there's a path kind of a path
yeah the fire's coming all right oh my
god
he has a gun i got more than a gun my
dude
i got way more than a gun way way more
than a gun
whoa
there i am ouchies
ah yeah i don't think there was any
getting out or maybe there was who knows
i have no idea maybe i could have run
all the way back but he said like there
was no point
so i believed him yeah that was
there was no getting out of this
[Music]
i think it's fitting i burned it in uh i
burned the tree in my dream and i burned
the tree in reality
whatever that pulsating white goop
monster was
that thing needed to die that thing
needed to die super hard
but man the the reality is making my
head spin
burn them all a great fire consumed the
woods for a couple days
gradually claiming many of its
[Music]
inhabitants
the fire consumed the last road leading
to the heart of the woods
so the road led to the heart not home
the doctor who did not wake up even as
the flames
came closer the three outcasts wearing
old rags in scrap who
grief stricken under the enormous
completely burnt tree
didn't even attempt to run was that the
three traitors
the old lady overgrown with mushrooms
who immobilized in a rocking chair
burned together with her hut
[Music]
the elephant family who did not leave
their home at the swamp even as the
flames started to consume it
the boy with the violin who remained
alone in the old hut at the swamp
without a chance of escape
the chicken lady who set out into the
woods in search of her sister and lost
the way
and the last living inhabitant of the
flooded village
consumed by the flames at the very end
of the road
leading home but not everyone perished
petric did not live to see the fire
before the flames of purity rose above
the treetops in his rocket made of scrap
as he looked through the small spaceship
window he smiled for the last time
the milky way stars looked so beautiful
even now
when moving away at a huge speed
the fate of the man with the wolf's
snout
remains unknown
[Music]
well i guess that means the only
survivor was the wolf i guess
what the hell crazy
that's nuts in the end i guess
to destroy the evil at the heart of the
woods you had to destroy the woods
and that meant destroying everyone in
the woods so it's clear that the woods
were real
and the town and the people in it were
real but that
isn't necessarily the same as saying
it wasn't all a dream as well because i
feel like
the mushrooms and the hallucinations
more specifically like if you spend so
long in a hallucination you
for you i guess you forget what's really
reality
and the the peak of that is going to the
heart of the woods where the tree's core
is the weird white goo and you end up at
the center of it all and just
you kind of lose everything of reality
and you slip completely into the
hallucination
but it was really there and so
burning it down was the only way to free
everyone from being trapped it really
like i think this is very reflective of
my
my my misguided attempts to save
everyone or at least
do what i thought was the right thing
because in the end the right thing
isn't necessarily the good thing and i
mean
uh besides from the things we're
obviously like i made mistakes obviously
but
that's crazy i really liked that i
really really enjoyed that
i think the fact that it made me feel so
strongly about my decisions is
reflective of
how well the game tells its story and i
think that this game is fantastic
i think on my own i will try to play a
different route
and just really take my time with it
because i i
like the way it played i liked the style
i liked how it came across and how it
told its story i
i like that and i like the gameplay and
i like the seriousness of it
and i like that you only have one chance
through a long playthrough
it's just a very good game an
exceptionally good game i think
everyone could enjoy playing this and
there's so many different paths that it
could have taken so
i highly encourage you to do so all my
frustration you know
i forgive the game for it because
obviously it's an indie game too like
it's it's tough to make a game and it's
tough to account for every single
possibility like me picking up so many
items i couldn't pick up the
flamethrower at the end there
that's strange but yeah this is great
link
is in the description you can find it on
steam thank you everybody so much for
watching it's been a while since i did
another long series like this
but this was worth it i'm so glad i did
so thank you
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]